oui l'une des dernière utilisation
justement prouvé de ses armes chimiques
l'a été pendant la guerre iran irak par
exemple les irakiens on utilise ont
utilisé ces armes contre les kurdes qui
étaient sur leur territoire d'où un
exode massif et 80 mille kurdes se sont
réfugiés en iran patricia cost et roger
motte se sont rendus il ya quelques
jours dans un de ces camps de réfugiés
reportage - 20° avant-hier soir dans les
montagnes du kurdistan
il fait nuit noire quand nous arrivons à
6 v un camp de réfugiés oubliés du monde
arriver mais au nom de dieu vous devriez
le savoir pourquoi me demander on a eu
le droit à tous les malheurs ils nous
ont arrosé avec des produits
il nous aux aveugles est assourdi rendu
fou ils vont tuer massacrer ils ont
exterminé nos familles anéanties nos
maisons voilà tout ce qui nous est
arrivé
la retirer nous a bombardé puis
l'aviation ils ont tous d'utiliser quoi
au mur les images de leurs villages
bombardés par les irakiens
oga cyanure ou ypérite commun à la pch à
ce nuage jaune est la seule preuve films
et de l'emploi des gaz par les irakiens
c est fait des centaines de personnes
fauchées en quelques secondes le but
pousser les kurdes a quitté le
territoire irakien
une partie d'entre eux après un séjour
en turquie son passé en iran à 6 v nous
les avons retrouvés je ne vaux rien pu
apporter avec tempo mais un verre de
rechange pour la lampe à pétrole a
dérapé
l'inventaire de personnes et caen sont
allés chercher du riz sont hors jeu les
sur la route les problèmes quels
problèmes chacun raf que l'autre
l'endroit où nous sommes pas la peine de
vous le décrire des baraques sont porte
sans fenêtre planté en plein vent l'imam
khomeiny nous est bien peu mais il a
lui-même ses difficultés
nous attendons des journées entières des
camions de nourriture sans savoir pierre
et jour à quelle heure il a rien à moins
polluer
car il n'y a pas des goûts les pompiers
et le pire c'est le froid le plastique
qu'on a mis aux fenêtres ne nous protège
pas et ce sont les enfants qui souffrent
le plus
je redis solennellement nous sommes dans
l'impossibilité d'assurer la survie d'un
âge enfants s'il n'y a pas une aide
extérieure
il y à bien un médecin au cours de 6 v
mais il ne se déplace pas il faut amener
les petits malades chez lui
là pas de chaussettes dans les danses
non
le docteur vient du bangladesh envoyé
par son gouvernement
on ne parle pas le kurde il ne voudra
pas nous dire combien il ya de décès par
jour
il se dit dans l'impossibilité de
diagnostiquer les cas d'intoxication par
gaz d'exxon money la conclusion est
terrible sous forme de prière ne vous
perdez pas de vue
agissez avec miséricorde pour que la
nation kurde ne disparaissent pas
si vous ne nous aidez pas tous ces films
seront ils les kurdes
un peuple presque oublié de dieu